what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Venom at long last and a
lot of you guys have been asking if
what's going on in the Carnage Comics
which we're covering is gonna cross over
with Venom yes Marvel's actually doing
an event called the death of the Venom
verse I think where basically Carnage is
going to be traveling around the
Multiverse killing every version of
Venom he can find it's gonna be dope I
am so excited about it but what this
does here right there's really not a ton
that happens here so it is interesting
but it does give us a chance to fill in
some of the gaps so one of the things to
remember here is that Eddie Brock as it
stands now is on a whole new level of
power that it only resides with regards
to the physical form meaning what he was
told in the last video that we did is
that Eddie Brock will become the
eventuality hence the reason why it has
its name Eddie Brock will eventually
become it but the thing about this is
that the eventuality is the antithesis
to the beyonders whether beyonders work
outside of the most Multiverse from the
beyondverse and have the ability to
alter reality on a near multiversal
scale right their power is astronomical
that the eventuality is very similar to
the same way the difference here is that
where the beyonders are more Hands-On
the eventuality is more hands-off and it
really just kind of watches but it
exists in the unbion the role of the
king in black or the eventuality was
created by the celestials it was given
an astronomical amount of power because
what's the point of being the antithesis
of the beyonders if you can't match them
in ability to at least counter them so
again Eddie Brock in the moment here
only has the ability to control
virtually anybody he inhabits and that's
why when they find the charred remains
of his physical form which had long
since been destroyed right that happened
like three or four videos ago that Eddie
Brock literally reconstitutes himself
seemingly out of nowhere now that's one
of the things that Eddie's able to do
you can almost imagine him being able to
jump from one host body to the next but
being able to control the atomic
structure of your own body is one step
away from being able to control reality
on an atomic or molecular level right I
mean it's just one adjustment one person
who writes a story a different way
somebody gives us an arc where Eddie's
able to suddenly control or turn like a
coffee pot into a mouse and suddenly
he's Off to the Races as a person with
the power of the beyonder so it's one of
those really weird and interesting
moments that I would urge you to keep in
the back of your head because it may
become astronomically important later on
down the line but one of the things to
remember is that the facility he wakes
up in is the facility controlled by
what's basically the absent Throne now
the absent thrown within Marvel Comics
still is not fully fleshed out so don't
blame yourself if you're not 100 sure
what it is because Marvel hasn't fully
explained it it's been heavily alluded
to that the absent Throne is actually a
different name given to the character of
Meridius which we'll talk about here
once we get towards the end of the comic
that's what it'll make the most sense to
do it but again we don't definitively
know we just know that it is an
organization or an object that operates
behind the scenes and basically
manipulates seemingly everything that
goes on so of course Eddie Brock
reconstituting himself he's now what's
called a living symbiote basically he is
a symbiote in human form he is imagine
the Venom symbiote suit itself except it
can just become Eddie Brock that's kind
of what's Happening Here he doesn't
actually have a true physical form
anymore and so of course you have all
these different guards and stuff who
show up and Eddie Brock kind of dodges
out of the way my initial thought here
is that when he goes and really hides
from him that it seems kind of silly but
at the same time I can kind of see that
happening because he's still figuring
out what his powers are and I don't
think his character has really evolved
to the point where he starts thinking
like a person with astronomical power
otherwise he would just pull like a
straight up Mia right put his hands out
stop the bullets from moving and then
help the soldiers finish with all their
living but following this after he
escapes the facility he ends up taking
out a security guard meeting with a
younger kid on a motorcycle and because
this kid's all about spray painting and
graffiti and there's huge allusions to
the uh film Terminator 2 that of course
Eddie Brock has this kid spray paint the
Venom symbol on the back of his leather
jacket and then he takes off and I gotta
tell you guys man never in my life did I
know that I needed to see any Brock as a
biker with the Venom symbol spray
painted on the back of a black leather
jacket I never knew I needed this but
now that I've seen it I knew that I did
this is amazing and I can't wait to see
how many people cosplay is this at
different Comic Cons but following that
we basically have Eddie Brock who
arrives at baywater now if you're not
caught up with Venom or if you've
forgotten because it's been a while
since we've done it Bay water is the
city where basically Eddie Brock's son
Dylan who has the I guess normal Venom
symbiote where he was kind of hanging
out for a little while he was ultimately
defeated and basically ended up leaving
and his story kind of goes in its own
Direction but baywater was basically
introduced to us as a town that's
effectively ran by bikers but again this
is one of the instances where the absent
throne is operating behind the scenes in
the sense that this town has now ran by
the absent Throne we don't really know
the significance of it I don't even know
if there was any real significance
established for it outside of the fact
that Dylan just happened to be there for
a period of time but when Eddie gets
here he realizes there's someone here
that he needs to go see and so of course
there's a cop who shows up that kind of
starts wielding his baton and making
some Idol threats right he starts a
fight with Eddie Brock and Eddie Brock
makes it his last one he takes this guy
out which is what happens right when you
mess with the Brock you get tanked like
a rock that was a terrible line I don't
know why I said that it seemed like it
made sense in the moment but the thing
about this
inter cringe but the thing about this is
that Eddie Brock's able to take these
guys out quite readily and even when
they're firing off bullets this is when
we start to get the full indication of
what it means to face off against Eddie
Brock these bullets just pass through
him right now we're not really given a
straight indication as to whether or not
they pass through him because he's kind
of intangible he's more of like a liquid
symbi form or because his body opens
holes for the bullets to pass through
the fact that Bullis travels so
astronomically fast what is it like 500
feet a second or something stupid like
that I think they're just passing
through him either that or he's just
like the fastest thinking person ever
and Eddie Brock has never been the
sharpest tool in the show nothing
against him right he's a cool guy you
know he's he's got to work counts but I
mean let's be honest guys like
he ain't always been the sharpest guy
but once he gets into the town proper
that's when he's basically met by Lynn
Drexler now again Lynn Drexler is not
overly significant here he's basically
the biker that took over the town and
he's just kind of been running it ever
since but once Eddie Brock gets in
there's this amazing moment when Lynn
realizes who Eddie Brock is now he
doesn't initially know this and in fact
he sees Eddie as more of just some kind
of a grifter who's just made his way
through and and he doesn't really know
what Eddie Brock's looking for or what
he wants but he goes so far as to say
that like the life Foundation has kind
of locked this place down he says
they're looking for some alien freak
they made their deal with the people in
charge and in this town that's the
hellhounds Right Lynn Drexler I run the
hellhounds now more than ever I own this
place and the funny thing about Eddie is
he responds and he's like no because
like one of the guys goes after him and
he's like okay look man right I mean if
this is how you guys want to do it this
is how we can do it just understand when
you mess with the ball you get the horns
one guy goes at him with a knife Eddie
Brock just slapped white literally snaps
his arm and then he kicks the other guy
in the face elbows another guy in the
head and it's like look guys I mean we
can here's the thing man
y'all are prepared right so like
literally takes these dudes out quite
readily but as soon as that's done he
points to the building and says I'm
looking for the guy in there now of
course that's when Len starts to realize
there's more to Eddie Brock than meets
the eye then he actually starts sending
his own guys after Eddie but even when
he goes to attack him Eddie Rogers
throws a knife in his hand takes the gun
out right the guy can't really shoot
anything anymore and he realizes Eddie
is exactly one of the kind of Symbiotes
or the aliens so to speak that the life
Foundation was referencing now one of
the things to know is the life
Foundation which is basically
subservient to the absent Throne they're
the ones that put the town on lockdown
that's one of the things to remember is
the action Throne is very rarely ever
physically involved right it's not as
though the absent Throne like meets with
uh the life foundation and says go do
this the closest we ever got to that was
Meridius but again we don't definitively
know if they're the same thing we can
largely assume they are but the thing
here is that the life Foundation is the
one that directed linen these guys but
Lynn totally misunderstands his place in
the bigger picture here right like he
thinks he's kind of hot to trot thinks
he's a big deal no and Eddie Brock calls
him out he's like look man you're just
the hired muscle but you were just
tasked here and you were told you're
important but at the end of the day if
you really were as important as you
think you are I wouldn't have taken you
out with the greatest of ease because
you would have had some measure of power
or some capability to be able to take me
out but the fact that you can't shows
you don't matter and so ultimately Eddie
Brock grabs this guy throws him into the
building and when he gets in there we
end up finding out the person he's
hunting for is bedlam now here's the
thing right here's a little bit of
explanation here for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with all this stuff
so Bedlam is kind of one of the
iterations of Eddie Brock one of the
things that's been established over the
course of the Venom comic so far is that
Eddie Brock being a king in Black he
kind of has like these different
iterations right Tyro and Meridius and
so on and so forth but each of these
guys are different stages right so
imagine for example that over the course
of your life right you turn 21 you can
go out and you can start drinking yay
right you turn 30 you buy your first
house that's really exciting you turn 40
and you're setting your career just kind
of cruising along and you turn 50 and
you retire now imagine that version of
yourself and each moment of your life
each one of those moments is a different
version of you right maybe one version
is really happy maybe one version is
really really sad that's how it works
with Eddie these different variations
like bedelum are just Eddie Brock at
different points in time after he became
the king in Black at the end of the king
and black event initially it was
believed that Meridius was his final
form but he figured out that wasn't the
case there was another form Beyond
Meridius and that's when he discovered
the eventuality if you're still a little
confused make sure you check the link to
the Venom playlist under the like button
that'll let you get caught up on
everything but the fact remains here
right it's awesome I'm really excited
about this I don't know what all they
have going on anymore Beyond this until
we get to like the main great big huge
Carnage versus Venom multiversal event
but I'm side with that being said guys
we're going to bring to an end thank you
all for watching and I will catch you
all later
peace